holy [ __ ] that was intense no escape
so no escape stars Owen Wilson a very
different kind of roll he's with his
family they're in Asia I don't know what
country it is it's not to say the movie
didn't tell me what country it was just
from my recollection a lot of times of
like Oh welcome to Asia I guess they're
in the country Asia but it's more of a
serious intense role for Owen Wilson
he's there on business he's there with
his family and then all of the sudden
militia just start taking over and
blowing people away it's chaos it's
murder and his family's right in the
middle of it's Owen Wilson needs to get
his family out of there first of all I
was impressed with Owen Wilson in this
role his comedic nature brought comedy
relief when you need to come not comedy
relief but it kind of eased the tension
in something you really buy him as this
average Joe dad who wants to get his
family out of this shitstorm and it
should be noted it's not like this sighs
killing that side they're just kind of
in the middle of making weasal
themselves out of it and no one really
notice no people are coming after them
because they are Americans not every
country is a fan of Americans but yeah
they're not not in the country Asia and
now to keep the YouTube tapes of
commenters I should be noted that I know
Asia is not a country it's a conference
a my remark about the country Asia you
know that implicates the countries that
make up the continent of Asia famine
notion only but trust me I read the
comments it has to be said and this
movie really was intense it reminded me
of Black Hawk Down but there are no
Marines they don't have weapons they're
just running and it reminded me of a
zombie apocalypse breaking out if the
zombies were sentient and used weapons
and hunted you down anime for some
intensity in this movie and you know
this movie would be so much easier and
less intense if he did not have kids
with him so a lot of times how do you
explain to your kid like a sweetie they
have machetes and machetes kill people I
know you're five years old but trust me
on this you really need to shut the [ __ ]
up it's stuff you want to make her feel
safe but you need to let her know that
not talking is really important right
now so it was perfect for this movie to
give him a family he needs to get out of
there can you really grab a date to that
you're like oh yeah I need to get the
family out of here [ __ ] like this scares
the hell out of me it really does it's
not ghosts
it's not ghouls it's not goblins it's
this kind of stuff because there are
countries that go through this [ __ ] now
it's a very real thing and it's terrible
to being plopped in the middle of this
as a civilians very affected a couple of
scenes in this movie you walk away from
going did the movie need that it was
because it was like really uncomfortable
in a couple of parts and without those
scenes the movie still would have been
and enjoyable but with those scenes it
adds an element of discomfort but it
really hits you in the face is like yeah
it's not pretty this is actually the
ugly so whatever the movie was trying to
do I gotta say it was really effective
in doing it guys in the end no escape
was very straightforward it doesn't take
long for the shitstorm to start [ __ ]
storming you're pulling for Owen Wilson
in this family you want to see them get
out of here it's a very brutal movie
it's uncomfortable but it is an intense
movement you walk out getting your
money's worth I will say no escape is a
good time no alcohol required only
question now is how long will it take
for someone to post a facebook article
or a YouTube video gun and the militia
and no escape we're actually the good
guys watch this your mind will be blown
boo be good and my sibling it'll happen
it's only a matter of time right guys so
no escape have you seen it what did you
think about it what's your favorite
escape movie of all time whatever it is
whatever you think comment below let me
know and as always if you like what
you've seen here and you want to see
more click right here to see more